in australia scientists have burned
10 pig carcasses in an unprecedented
experiment
they're trying to answer a question from
the other side of the globe
what happened to these 43 students who
disappeared in mexico
two years ago the mexican government
maintains that the students from a
teacher's college
were kidnapped by a drug cartel they say
their bodies were incinerated atop a
pile of wood and tires
in a trash dump in the town of cucula
several bags of human remains burned to
ash
were found in the dump and in a nearby
river
last summer fire scientist jose carrero
went to kakula
to investigate the government's story he
saw no signs of a massive fire
what's more there was virtually no
organic material
left in their remains that suggests they
were burned
in a crematorium not an open-air fire
he decided to do some experiments to be
sure working with pig carcasses
torero used wood fuel to burn anywhere
from one
to four pigs at a time he found that
over 700 kilograms of wood was needed
to burn one pig carcass to the point
where there was almost no
organic matter left burning more than
one body at a time
required even more fuel per body
according to these results
burning 43 bodies would require over 30
000 kilograms of wood this suggests that
the students bodies were likely
not burned in the dump their final hours
are still unaccounted for
with the dump site ruled out it seems
investigators should continue to look
elsewhere
you